The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
for the next six lectures,
including today, we're
going to finish off
the course with the
application of everything
we've studied so far
to a couple of ideas.
The first being the existence
of solids-- why we have solids
and why we have conductivity
in solids, which
is basic properties
of materials.
In particular, the story I want
you guys to leave the course
with is an understanding of
why diamonds are transparent
and why copper
isn't, which is sort
of a crude fact about the world.
But we can explain it
from first principles,
which is pretty awesome.
The second is we're going to
come back to this idea of spin
and of 1/2 integral
angular momentum.
This intrinsic angular
momentum of the electron.
And we're going to use that
to motivate a couple of ideas.
First off, we're going to
tie back to Bell's inequality
from the very beginning,
and then we're
going to do a little bit
on quantum computation.
That will be the
last two lectures.
So before I get started
though with today, two things.
First, I'm going to
ask for questions.
But the second is I got
some really good questions
about hydrogen, so
I want to wrap up
with one last
comment on hydrogen
because it's entertaining.
But before I get started
on that, questions
about everything up till now?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in the
[INAUDIBLE] there's
someting called spirit orbit
couplings, another edition,
the [INAUDIBLE], that
we haven't talked about,
in addition throughout
this egression.
Is that something we can
do with our knowledge now?
Or is something [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It absolutely is.
So the question is-- and this
is a very good question--
the question is, look,
if you look on Wikipedia
about-- seriously, this
is a rational thing to do.
If you look at Wikipedia
to learn something
about hydrogen,
what you discover
is everything
we've talked about,
including the fine structure,
including the Zeeman effect.
But you see that there are
a couple of other effects.
So one effect, for example,
is when you look at the Zeeman
effect a little more
carefully than we did,
there's a second term in
the Zeeman effect, which
is an induced magnetic moment.
So even when the
angular momentum
is smaller or even
zero, there's still
a contribution to the energy
from the externally imposed
magnetic field.
So there are lots of
other corrections.
One of them in
particular is something
called spin orbit coupling.
And so the question
was, what is that?
And do we know enough to explain
what spin orbit coupling is?
So let me give you a very
short answer to that question.
So we know that if we
write down the energy
operator for our system, we
have the energy operator--
so the full energy operator
for hydrogen, I'll say,
is the energy
operator for coulomb
plus a bunch of corrections.
So for example, we had the
relativistic correction
plus a term that was
a coefficient times
p to the fourth.
And this is on your problem set.
And this came from
relativistic corrections.
I shouldn't call this c.
I'll call it beta, maybe.
Some coefficient.
And there are a whole bunch
of other contributions.
For example, there's
the term we studied
that contributed to
the Zeeman effect.
If there's an external
magnetic field,
there's a B dot-- magnetic
moment of the system.
And if the electron is in
a state with finite angular
momentum, the magnetic moment is
some dimensionful coefficient,
which we usually call
the Bohr magneton just
because-- whatever--
we liked the guy.
Times the angular momentum.
But there can be
additional contributions.
There are a whole bunch
of additional terms
in the true potential
for hydrogen.
One of them takes
the following form.
It's a constant plus-- maybe
I'll call it kappa times
spin dotted into the angular
momentum of the electron,
of the electron bound
to the hydrogen system.
So where this comes from is
a sort of beautiful story.
So first off, could it be there?
Sure.
This is a term that could
exist with some coefficient.
Why not?
It turns out that you
can derive its existence
from a study of the relativistic
version of the hydrogen system.
We're not going to study
that in any detail in 804,
but the basic idea
and what this does
is totally amenable
to 804-level analysis.
This is just saying that when
you have some orbital momentum,
or when you have some spin
angular momentum, both of those
corresponds to angular
momentum of an object that
carries charge.
And so it's not
unreasonable that there's
going to be some
interaction between the two
where the magnetic moments--
those two magnetic moments
either want to be aligned
or anti-aligned depending
on the sign of this coefficient.
However, we haven't talked about
spin in any great detail yet.
We're going to do that in
the last week of the course.
So I'm going to defer talking
about this in any detail.
And we're only going
to discuss it briefly
at the end for a
couple of weeks.
But absolutely, these
additional couplings
are important for
hydrogen and they're also
things you can study at
this level, at 804 level.
I should also
emphasize that there
are a whole bunch of
other corrections.
There are lots of terms.
One set of terms, an
infinite number of terms,
are the further sub-leading
relativistic corrections
of kinetic energy.
And there are a whole
bunch of other corrections,
so I'm going to leave
those out for the moment.
But I want to emphasize
to everyone that we're
building models of hydrogen,
and they're all approximations.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's a question
regarding this [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
There is.
So on the problem
set, you're asked
to estimate the
correction to the energy.
I wrote down the answer
in lecture the other day.
You're asked to compute, in
particular, the l dependence.
But to estimate the
magnitude or to estimate
the value of the shift
in the energy eigenvalues
to hydrogen from the first
relativistic correction
is p to the fourth correction.
And I expect that
this will be covered
in your recitation in some
detail, but there the question
was, is there a trick to
make this a little easier?
There are a couple of
good physical arguments,
which I'm not going to tell you.
But there are nice
ways to do this.
But at the end of
the day, you do not
want to end up doing the
following computation.
You don't want to take
the expectation value of p
to the fourth and
write this as the sum
integral of psi
complex conjugate
derivative to the fourth psi.
If you attempt to do this
integral, you will weep.
This is not the way
you want to do it.
And here's what you want to do.
And I'm not going to
tell you how to get here,
but you want to reduce the
calculation of this expectation
value to the calculation of
the expectation value of 1
over r and of 1 over r squared.
And it turns out that if you
know these expectation values,
that entirely suffices to
compute the expectation
value of p to the fourth if
you take into account the fact
that the energy eigenfunctions
satisfy the original energy
eigenvalue equation.
So p squared upon 2m
plus v of x of v of r
is equal to e when acting
on those wave functions.
So for computing
these guys, you could
try to do this brute force,
not unrelated to problem,
I believe, two on Rydberg
atoms on the problem set.
But there are
actually sneakier ways
to do these expectation
values as well.
And I will leave that to you.
But let me emphasize that you
can do a direct brute force
calculation, but
you don't need to.
And I would encourage
you to try to find
an efficient, indirect way
to do these calculations.
Did that answer your question?
OK.
Anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is [INAUDIBLE]
a time dependence
to an operator with the
[INAUDIBLE] being [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Does
adding-- well, it
depends on how you introduce
the time dependents.
AUDIENCE: Can a
operator [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yeah, absolutely.
What's the reason
for the question?
AUDIENCE: One of
the problems here.
PROFESSOR: One of the
problems in the problem set?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's like the last part of four.
PROFESSOR: Remind me
which problem this
is, I don't remember.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Oh, oh!
Ha, ha, ha.
Sorry, I really
like that problem.
Let me rephrase your question
in the following way.
Is it intrinsically
non-Hermitian
to have time
dependence in a system?
So no, you can have-- so
what does Hermitian mean?
Physically, what does
it mean for the energy
to be Hermitian for example?
What it means for
the energy operator
to be Hermitian is that time
evolution, which is represented
by the oper-- so let
me phrase it this way.
So if we know that the
energy operator is Hermitian,
what is that telling us?
Well, it tells us
a lot of things.
It tells us the energy
eigenvalues are real.
That's good.
So E dagger is equal to E.
But it tell us something else.
Remember that the
Schrodinger equation
is that ih bar dt on psi
is equal to E on psi.
And we use this to argue
that the general solution
to the Schrodinger
equation can be written
in the following
elegant way, psi of t
is equal to e to the minus
i upon h bar tE on psi at 0,
where this was the
evolution operator u sub t.
Yeah?
And this is a unitary operator.
And the way they say its
unitary goes back to the exam.
The way to say it's
unitary is this
is e to the i
Hermitian operator.
t is a real number,
h is a real number.
So this is e to the
i Hermitian operator.
And anything of the form e
to the i Hermitian operator
is unitary.
It's adjoint to its inverse.
What that tells you is
that since this is unitary,
it preserves the magnitude, or
the norm, of the wave function.
So probability is conserved.
What would it mean for
the energy operator
to be not Hermitian?
Well, it would mean
a lot of things.
One thing it would mean is
that the energy eigenvalues
are no longer real.
That's a little weird.
But the much more
troubling thing
is that the energy would
no longer be-- sorry,
the probability would
no longer be conserved.
The evolution operator, which is
the solution to the Schrodinger
equation, would no longer
be a unitary operator.
And the probability, the
norm or the wave function,
would no longer be conserved.
So the question at the
end of-- the last question
in problem four
is really asking,
in the system you're
thinking about
is, probability conserved?
And that's the question that
you should be asking yourself
when you finish up problem four.
Good?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When we solve
the Schrodinger equation
in that way, does this
solution come from the fact
that E is Hermitian or that
E is like that nice little
[INAUDIBLE], that E
is time dependent.
And that if E was
time dependent,
why couldn't the coefficients
for the probability also be?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So here I was just focusing
on the Hermiticity.
And in solving
this, I'm assuming
that the energy is
time independent.
If the energy is not
time independent,
then this is not the right
answer as you're pointing out.
So in fact, you have
to do an integral
and you have to
time order things,
and it's a complicated story.
But this is not the solution.
But even if we have a
time independent system,
if the energy operator is not
Hermitian, this is not unitary.
So indeed, you're absolutely
right that if the energy
operator is time
dependent, the story's
more complicated than just this.
But we already see the problem
that's salient for problem four
at this stage with a time
independent operator.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just one
question please.
So if I had some sort of
system which is [INAUDIBLE],
some of my particles are
weak in the other process.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And now the
probability is not conserved.
Saying that this thing is not
[INAUDIBLE], the issue is,
I think, which is also extremely
disturbing for [INAUDIBLE]
complex in energy,
[INAUDIBLE], what is that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That seems even worse.
PROFESSOR: Well, I guess
it's a matter of taste.
I would say that they're the
same thing in the following
sense.
Suppose I have complex
energy eigenvalues.
Well, I know that if I
have a stationary state,
then that stationary state
as a function of time
is equal to the stationary
state at time 0 times
e-- so this is an energy
eigenfunction rather than-- is
e to the minus i the
energy times t over h bar?
Or this is the
energy eigenvalue.
Now, imagine e is complex.
Sorry, first imagine e is real.
That's not hard to imagine
because it's usually the case.
And if that's true, what
happens to the wave function
as we evolve through time?
It rotates by phase.
Now, if e is complex, imagine
e is of the form e-- let e
be complex.
So e is going to be E real minus
i gamma, some imaginary piece.
So what that's going to give me
is an e to the minus gamma t.
And that's a decaying thing that
when you get to norm squared
gives you a decaying
envelope over time.
It's going to give you
an exponential decay.
This is going to be equal
to e to the minus ie
real t over h bar times
e to be minus gamma
t over h bar phi of 0.
And when we take the norm
squared, the phase goes away,
but this doesn't.
So having loss of probability
is having a complex energy
eigenvalue.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why are we
talking about time
independent operators if
there's an electromagnetic field
and stuff is clearly going
on between the avenue
of the electromagnetic field?
PROFESSOR: This is a
very good question.
And that actually
leads me into the thing
I wanted to talk about first.
So I got a bunch of questions--
thanks for that question.
I got a bunch of questions
over the past few days
about the magnetic moment of
the hydrogen system and what
a strange idea that is.
So let me talk about
that for a second.
And when I'm done with
this little spiel,
tell me if I've
answered your question.
Well, let's just leave this up.
OK.
So in particular, let's think
about this term for a moment.
Where this term came from
last time was we said,
look, we turn on an
external magnetic field.
Someone turns on the
switch and current runs
through an electromagnet and
we get a uniform magnetic field
in our fiducial volume, where
we're doing the experiment.
And the electron system, if it
carries some angular momentum,
it also has a charge,
angular momentum charge.
That means it's got
a magnetic moment.
That's how much magnetic moment.
So this is saying that the
magnetic moment of the electron
bound to the proton
with angular momentum
wants to anti-align
with the magnetic field.
Or align in this case
because I put the wrong sign.
But here's something really
upsetting about that.
So what I just said
sounds crazy if you
think about it in
the following way.
Take an electron in
the coulomb system,
just straight up coulomb.
Take an electron in
the coulomb system,
put it in, say, the ground
state, lowest energy state.
Is it moving?
This is problem four.
So is it moving?
The expectation
value of position
doesn't change in time.
It's a stationary state.
Expectation value of
nothing changes in time.
OK, fine, but it's
the ground state
that carries your
angular momentum.
That's not so upsetting.
Go to the first excited
state with angular momentum.
The n equals 2, l equals
1, m equals 1 state.
So it's got as much angular
momentum in lz as possible.
Is that thing moving?
Yeah.
It's not moving at all.
And yet, we're saying
there's a current associated
with it, an electric current.
And that electric current is
inducing a magnetic moment,
a la right-hand rule.
Maybe via Biot-Savart,
if you want to be fancy.
And that magnetic moment--
a little current loop--
is leading to this interaction,
the Zeeman's interaction.
We know that it's true because
experiments show the Zeeman
splitting.
So it is definitely
true that there
is a magnetic moment
of this thing.
But it's not moving,
how can that be?
So how can there be a
current if nothing is moving?
AUDIENCE: It is, in some
sense moving, [INAUDIBLE].
Why is the expectation value of
the [INAUDIBLE] to stop moving?
PROFESSOR: What's
the expectation
value of the momentum?
AUDIENCE: I think
it's also probability.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's 0.
AUDIENCE: I mean, first of
all, the world isn't classical.
You can't use
classical intuition.
PROFESSOR: OK, true.
AUDIENCE: Second of
all, let's suppose
you have a uniform ring
of classical charge
and set it spinning.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That ring is
as a ring, not moving,
but there's still a
current associated with it.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
that the electron is a ring?
AUDIENCE: It might make sense
if you give it that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I like this.
No, this is good.
It's wrong, but it's good.
And the reason it's good
is that you're really
pushing your assumptions
to try to figure out
how the experimental
data can possibly match.
And you're saying, look, we have
to just reject our intuition.
Our intuition is clearly
leading us astray.
And I like that.
That's correct.
So what we're going to do
in the next few minutes
is work through that and try
to find the best way to phrase
that.
Your strategy is
the correct one.
So let me rephrase
that slightly.
Look, if you have a classical
distribution of charge,
that distribution
of charge could
be a stationary
distribution-- a distribution,
which as a distribution of
charge doesn't change a dime.
But each individual charge
in that distribution
is itself moving.
The problem here is that we
just have the one electron.
If you ever look, you will
find the electron at a spot.
But what you're really
saying is, look,
it's a mistake to think
about the electron having
a definite position
in the first place.
You just shouldn't
think about that.
The best you can
say is that it has
some probability of
being in any spot.
So let's work with that.
Let's take that idea
and let's push it.
Let's see how far we can take
this idea that the electron has
some probability [INAUDIBLE].
So suppose we have an
electron in a stationary state
of the coulomb potential.
The stationary
states are labeled
by three integers-- n, l, and m.
And we'd written
their wave functions.
There are, of course, an
infinite number of ways
to write in different notation.
There are an infinite
number of fonts one
could use for the normalization
constant 1/r R nl of little
r, Y lm of theta and phi.
And I'm going to rewrite this.
I'm going to expand
this out slightly.
This is N 1/r R of R and l.
And Ylm, remember, was of the
form Pl of cosine theta times
e to the im phi.
Everyone cool with that?
So I just wrote the spherical
harmonic as a polynomial
in cosine theta times
an exponential in phi.
AUDIENCE: Where did the
1/r come from, on the left?
PROFESSOR: The 1/r
was-- so most people
call capital R the whole thing.
But this is the
pulling out to 1/r
to simplify the
radio wave equation.
And the reason I
prefer writing it
this way is just that
this guy satisfies
a simple 1d
Schrodinger equation.
AUDIENCE: That was the u of r?
PROFESSOR: That was a thing
that we called u of r,
and then I confused the
hell out of everyone
by calling three different
things on the board
u, which was sort
of unnecessary.
So this is the artist
previously known as u.
The dude can sing.
OK, so the first
question I want to ask
is, so this is a
stationary state.
Is the electron moving?
No, not in any
conventional sense.
If you compute the expectation
value of the position
and you take its time
derivative, this is zero.
We could do this either
by calculating it
or just by observing that
it's a stationary state.
And on principle, it
can't change in time.
So this guy is not moving
in any conventional sense.
So why is there an
electric current?
Why do we get the Zeeman
magnetic moment, the Bohr
magneton?
So as was pointed out, look,
this is quantum mechanics.
It's not classical mechanics.
And in quantum mechanics, the
electron isn't at any point.
Rather, there's some
probability density.
And the probability
density that we
find the electron at
some point r is psi
squared l m or r squared.
A familiar beast.
And meanwhile, a wonderful
thing about the probability
distribution in
quantum mechanics
that we've already discussed
here is that it's conserved.
The time derivative of the
probability density or r--
remember, this is a
density, not a probability.
The time rate of change of
the probability distribution
is minus the gradient-- the
divergence of the probability
current, where the
probability current j
is equal to h bar
over the mass, which
I'm going to call the mass mu.
Oh, gee, I don't
want-- I'm going
to call the mass
capital M. That's
the mass of the
electron, which is
a little strange because
it's a very small quantity.
But anyway, h over capital
M of the imaginary part
of psi complex
conjugate gradient psi.
And you showed on a problem
set long ago that this is true
if j takes this form by virtue
of the Schrodinger equation.
Now, we usually write this
imaginary 1 over 2i times psi
gradient-- or psi star gradient
psi minus psi gradient psi
star, but that's equal
to the imaginary part
of the first term.
The thing you want to emphasize
is the imaginary part.
So we have this current.
In our system, the
position expectation value
is time independent.
And indeed, it's a
stationary state.
So beyond the position
expectation value being time
independent, the
probability density
itself is time independent
because the wave function
evolves by an overall phase
and the probability density
is the norm squared.
So the phase goes away.
So in our system, in an
electron in this state
in the coulomb
potential, the time rate
of change of the
probability density--
let me actually
do this over here.
So in the stationary
state, psi l, n, m,
the time rate of change
of the density is 0.
And this tells us by the
conservation equation
that the divergence of
the current is also 0.
Does that tell us
that the current is 0?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what's the current?
Well, we've written everything
here in spherical coordinates.
And the current is given in
terms of the gradient operator.
So let me remind you quickly of
what the gradient operator is
in spherical coordinates.
It has three components--
a radial component,
a theta component, and
then a phi component.
And the radial part is just D r.
The theta component
is 1 over r D theta.
And the phi around
the equator component
is equal to 1 over
r sine theta D phi.
Everyone cool with that?
So what's j?
Well, j is going to
have a component, j
in the radial direction.
The current in the
radial direction.
And intuitively,
what should that be?
Is there stuff going out or in?
There shouldn't be.
It's hydrogen.
It's not doing this.
So this should be 0.
And we can just
quickly see that this
is h bar upon M imaginary
part of-- well, this
is the r component, it's
going to be the derivative
in the radial direction.
But the derivative in the radial
direction is going to be real.
The derivative in the radial
So when we take
the norm squared,
we don't pick up anything.
We pick up an
overall coefficient.
It's going to be strictly real.
The phase, e to the
i m phi cancels out
because this is the
complex conjugate.
So the imaginary part of
this thing is going to be 0.
OK?
So J r is 0.
And similarly, J theta
p is a real function.
When we take a derivative,
we get a real function.
And then when we multiply
by its complex conjugate,
again, the phase
cancels out and we just
get a whole bunch of real stuff
whose imaginary piece is 0.
So J theta is 0.
But J phi is a cool one.
In my head, I was
just thinking J 5.
OK, at least someone got that.
So J phi, however,
is not going to be
0 for the following reason.
So what is it equal to?
It's equal to h bar
upon M-- the mass,
M-- times the imaginary
part of-- well,
psi star, which is
psi complex conjugate.
And then the gradient
with respect to phi.
The phi component is
1 over r sine theta.
And then derivative
with respect to phi.
The derivative with respect
to phi pulls down a i m.
Oh, look-- times psi, which
is equal to h bar upon m,
times-- well, psi
is norm squared.
That's real.
Psi squared.
1/r sine theta.
That's real, so I
can pull that out.
And we are left
with imaginary part
of im, which is just
m, which is not 0.
And in particular, it's
proportional to h bar m.
Everyone see that?
So what this is saying is that
the current, the probability
current, for an electron
in the stationary state psi
nlm of the Coulomb potential
is equal to norm psi squared
over m r sine theta h bar
m in the phi direction.
The phi uni-vector.
Cool?
So nothing is moving,
but there's a current.
What is moving?
What is the thing of
whose current-- of whom
this is the current?
AUDIENCE: Probability density.
PROFESSOR: The
probability density.
The probability
density is rotating.
So what this is telling
us is that it's true
the system is stationary.
But I want to know-- I'm looking
down at the equatorial plane,
OK.
So this plot is going
to be looking down
on the equatorial
plane of hydrogen.
Here is the origin, the
center of the potential.
And what this is
telling-- so I'm
going to draw these vectors.
They're in e phi direction.
OK.
But their magnitude
falls off with 1
over r and the norm square
of the wave function, which
also is falling
off exponentially.
And it goes to 0 at the
origin as r to the l plus 1.
And m must be no bigger than l.
So in order for m to be
non-zero, l must be non-zero.
Which means this must go like r
to the something greater than m
plus 1.
So the r's cancel out.
And we have that it vanishes.
So the contribution
vanishes at the origin,
is small near the origin,
is largest at some radius,
and then falls off again.
So the magnitude
of the arrow here
is meant to indicate the
magnitude of the flux.
So what we see is that we have
a probability distribution where
the probability,
as a distribution,
is time independent.
Right?
The probability distribution
is, in fact, time independent.
But there's a current which is a
persistent, stationary current.
Everyone cool with that?
So if I ask you,
where is the particle?
Well, the probability
density tells you that.
And if I ask you,
what's the current?
The electric current,
minus e times j.
At a point.
And this is really the current
density and the probability
current density.
Now what is the consequence of
the statement, the probability
density itself is
not changing in time.
It's that there is zero
divergence of this current.
And indeed, there
is zero divergence.
Every little bit
going into a spot
is matched by some
equivalent amount going out.
There's zero divergence.
Cool?
And so we see that while it's
true that nothing is moving,
it is also true that there is
a non-trivial electric current.
And when you use
the Biot-Savart law
to sum up the contributions
from each little bit
of this current, what you
get is-- right hand rule--
a magnetic field,
a magnetic moment.
And following nothing
but the Biot-Savart law
and using what you know
about the wave functions,
this gives us that the magnetic
moment is equal to the Bohr
magneton, b times m, z.
OK?
Everyone cool with that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when the perimeter
intuitively is [INAUDIBLE],
still make all these
other expectation values?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is that
an intuitive force?
Or maybe it's not.
PROFESSOR: Well, here's
one way to say it.
There are two-- let me
rephrase that question.
Let me give you a
different question to ask.
And let's think about the
answers to that question
and I hope that will
answer your question,
if it doesn't ask it again.
So here's the question I
would suggest that you ask.
Or that someone ask.
I'll ask it.
And I just totally lost
my train of thought.
That's totally me.
What was the question
I wanted you to ask?
Wow, that's amazing.
I completely just in the blink
of an eye totally lost my train
of -- ah, yes.
So here, it was crucial
in this calculation
that the current was given
by the imaginary part
of the gradient.
And as you showed in a problem
set a while back, anytime
you have a wave
function which is real,
then the current will vanish.
Here it was crucial--
in order to get
a non-vanishing
current-- it was crucial
that the wave
function was not real.
It had a phase.
But you also showed
on a problem set
that you can always take
your energy eigenfunctions--
for bounce-- you can always
take your energy eigenfunctions
and make them real.
You can always construct a
basis of energy eigenfunctions
which are strictly real.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: In one
dimension, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah well--
AUDIENCE: Aren't
you in three also?
PROFESSOR: What did
you use for that proof?
AUDIENCE: Just used linear
combination of the two.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You just use the energy
eigenvalue equation,
hermiticity, and the
linear, the energy operator.
And that's perfectly true
in any number of dimensions.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So that sounds crazy.
So first off, why do we have a
not real energy eigenfunction?
Can we construct purely
real energy eigenfunctions?
If we can, those
energy eigenfunctions
would appear to have no current.
So they would have
no magnetic moment.
How do these fit together?
Can you construct
energy eigenfunctions
that are pure real
for this system,
for the Coulomb potential?
Let me give you a hint.
In 1d for a free particle, what
are the energy eigenfunctions?
1d,
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
PROFESSOR: E to the ikx, right?
That's not real.
But there's another
eigenfunction,
you get the minus ikx.
And if you take
the sum of those,
you get e to the ikx
plus e to the minus
ikx-- divide by 2 for fun-- and
that gives you cosine of kx.
That's real.
But there's a
second one, which is
sine of kx, which is also real.
Now you can take linear
combinations of them
with i's and get the
exponentials back.
But let's just take
the real part, right?
Now, do those
carry any momentum?
What's the momentum expectation
value for cosine of kx?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0, because
you get confirmation
from plus k and
one from minus k.
They exactly cancel.
Now look at this solution.
Can you construct a real
energy eigenfunction
of the Coulomb potential?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: How.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Great..
Let's take this and
its complex conjugate.
So what that would be?
Well, if we take this, psi nlm.
And its complex conjugate, well,
what is its complex conjugate?
These are real.
That just gives me a minus.
So that's the state
plus psi and l minus
m, which is also an allowed
state with the same energy
by rotational invariance.
And this is thus
the state psi nl.
And it doesn't have a definite
lz angular momentum, right?
So I'll just call it
psi sub nl unhappy face.
It is not an lz eigenfunction.
But it is an energy
eigenfunction.
And it could also have
built a minus with divide
by 2i for fun.
I could have built the
sine or the cosine of phi.
One of which showed
up on your exam.
So I can find a basis of
these states, sine and cosine,
instead of, give me the im
phi, I need the minus im phi.
And those would have
been perfectly real.
And in those situations, what
would the current have been?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If I put the system
in this stationary state,
what would the
current have been?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: Identically 0.
However, that wouldn't be a
state with a definite angular
momentum.
So it wouldn't be surprising
that it has zero current.
It's got some contribution.
It's a super position of
having some angular momentum
and having the opposite
angular momentum.
And the expectation value,
the expected value, is zero.
I can also study states with a
definite value of the angular
momentum.
Those are not real.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I could have
constructed states which
don't have a definite angular
momentum but are real.
But instead, I want
to work with states
that have a definite
angular momentum.
That cool?
So there's no tension.
There's no contradiction.
It's just that, if we're
interested in finding states
that have a definite energy and
a definite lz angular momentum,
that is not going to
be a real function.
And nothing tells us
that it has to be.
And when you have
a non-trivial lz,
when you have a non-trivial
angular momentum, just
like a classical particle
with nontrivial angular
momentum that has charge, we
find that there's a current.
And thus a magnetic moment.
So the important thing with
having a definite nonzero
momentum, or in this
case angular momentum,
to give us the current.
Yeah?
Questions about this?
AUDIENCE: Using the same
logic, it kind of looks
like we're taking it
a charged particle
and moving it around in circles.
Like, where we
have a distribution
and we're spinning.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: With spin a
distribution of charge,
we're accelerating the
charged particles in it.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Individually.
AUDIENCE: If we accelerate
them, they emit radiation.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hydrogen atoms
don't emit radiation.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How does that go?
PROFESSOR: That sounds
a lot like problem four
on your problem set.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, OK.
Well, that's a great question.
And you should think about it.
How could I say--
you read my mind.
Yes.
Struggling with this is
exactly the point of one
of the problems on
your problem set.
And ask me that again after the
problem set has been turned in,
and I'll give you a
happy disquisition on it.
But I want you to
struggle with it.
Because it's hard and
interesting question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I don't think this
answers my question necessarily
about the radiation.
Because, analogously,
the classical enm,
this would be the
magnetostatic case,
where you just have a static--
PROFESSOR: Precisely.
Precisely.
AUDIENCE: But with
radiation, you have, quickly
oscillating fields and
the transition times
are really small and the
frequencies of the wave
functions are really fast.
So I still don't know
if that's the same.
PROFESSOR: So this
question is unfortunately
a linear combination of a
really good independent question
and that question.
So ask me after the
lecture and I'll
talk to you about the part
that's linearly independent.
OK.
I'm on thin ice here.
Anything else before we
dispense with hydrogen?
OK.
The question that
you all keep coming
to about the-- well,
problem four on the-- I
think it's problem four
on the problem set.
Maybe it's problem two.
It involves almost
no computation,
but it's the most intellectually
challenging problem
on the exam-- on
the problem set.
So take it seriously, even
though it's calculation-free.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Due to this
proton in the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's so that the--
it's not by symmetry,
because there isn't a symmetry.
The proton is 2,000 times
heavier than the electron.
But-- let me make sure I'm
understanding your question.
Your question is, we
found that the electron is
in bound states in
the Coulomb potential.
But in hydrogen,
you have two parts,
you have an electron
and a proton.
So is the electron in
that state and the proton
is just free and cruising
on its own thing?
That's exactly the topic
of the next 45 minutes.
OK.
Good question.
So with that insight,
let me turn now
to the question of
identical particles
or multiple particles.
OK.
So we're done with
Coulomb for the moment.
Pretty much for the
rest of the course.
So I want to move on to
the following question.
Suppose I have a system-- we've
spent a lot of time thinking
about a particle in a potential.
I would like to think
about multiple particles
for a minute.
And neat things happen
for multiple particles
that don't happen for
individual, isolated particles.
So let's think
about what those--
let's think about the physics
of multiple particles.
So in particular, classically--
in classical mechanics--
if I have two particles,
what is the information
I have to specify?
I have to specify the state.
I have to specify the position
of the first particle.
X1 and its momentum, p1.
And then the position of the
second particle x2 and p2.
I'm going to omit
vectors over everything,
but everything is in
the appropriate number
of dimensions.
So in classical mechanics--
in quantum mechanics,
the state of the
system is specified
by a wave function, which is
a function of the positions--
or the degrees of freedom,
let's say x1 and x2.
And x1 and x2 and p1
and p2 are promoted
to operators representing
these observables.
And the wave function
is a function--
now let me just quickly tell
you what this notation means.
What this notation means is
x1 is some number, like 7.
And the quantity
in the first spot,
this means that the
first particle indicated
by the first slot, is at x1.
And the second
particle is at x2.
So whenever I write a
wave function, what I mean
is this is the probability
amplitude-- the thing
whose norm squared is
probability-- to find
the first particle at this
value and the second particle
of that value.
So the 1 and 2 label the
points, not the particles.
The particle is labeled by
the position inside this wave
function.
Everyone cool with that?
OK.
So that's just a notation.
So the quantum mechanical
description of two particles
is a wave function of both
positions and operators
representing the position
and the coordinates
of the particles.
And the probability--
actually, let's
go ahead and finish up here--
and the probability density
to find the first particle.
First at x1, and
the second at x2.
It's just the norm squared
of the amplitude, psi x1, x2,
norm squared.
Just as usual.
That's the probability density.
All right?
Everyone cool with that?
And what are x1, x2, commutator?
What is this commutator?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Can you know the
position of the first particle
and the position of
the second particle?
Simultaneously?
Sure.
I'm here.
You're there.
0.
And x1 with p1-- just work in
one dimension for the moment--
is equal to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Our h bar.
And the same would have
been true of x2 and p2.
And what about x1 with p2?
0.
These are independent
quantities.
OK.
So it's more or less
as you'd expect.
So just to be explicit about
this, let's do an example.
Two free particles.
So what's the energy operator?
Well, the energy operator is
equal to p squared upon 2m
for the first particle, 1,
plus p squared 2 upon 2m 2.
Second particle, its mass is m2.
The first particle has mass m1.
And the system is free,
so this is plus 0.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for the
[INAUDIBLE] exponentially,
is that true [INAUDIBLE]
particles [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So the question is, x1,
x2, commutator equals 0?
Is that true even if there are
forces between the particles?
So what are the forces
between particles--
what are they going
to contribute to?
Yeah, the potential.
And that's going to show
up in the energy operator.
So that will certainly
matter and it
will change what the
energy eigenvalues are.
But it won't tell what
can or can't be measured.
It won't tell you what
properties the system can have
or not.
Good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's
with the particles
in the state in which
measuring the position of one
makes the position of the
other one in certainty?
PROFESSOR: We'll talk about
things like that in a minute.
AUDIENCE: Does it screw this up?
PROFESSOR: No.
This is-- do the
commutation relations
care what state you're in?
They're relations
amongst operators.
So they're independent
of the state always.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For the
two free particles,
are we assuming that they're
not charged particles?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm assuming that there are
no interactions whatsoever.
Just totally free particles.
Potential is zero.
V of x1, x2 equals 0.
So they're not charged.
They're just totally
uninteresting.
No interactions, no
forces, no potential.
OK.
So we know how to
solve this problem
because we can use separation.
Psi of x1, x2 can be
written as-- well,
we know what the solutions
of p1 upon 2m is equal to er.
So we can write
this as chi of x1.
And actually, I'm going
to call the positions
of these guys a and b.
Because the subscriptions
are just terribly misleading.
So the first point is called a,
the second point is called b.
So a and b.
And this is p1 and p2 the
momentum of the two guys.
Chi of a and phi of b.
So all I'm doing here
is I'm using separation.
Pa, pb.
So here's, instead of calling
the positions x1 and x2,
I'm going to call them a
and b just because it's
going to be easier to write
and make things clear.
So I'm using separation.
And then p1 squared, or
pa squared, upon 2m on cih
of a is equal to ea, chi a.
And ditto for b.
This tells us that
chi of a is equal to e
to the sub-coefficient
c, e to the i k a.
Everyone cool with that?
A is just replacing x1.
So it's just the position.
So this is just saying
that the solution
to a single free
particle is a plane wave.
And because it's just the
sum of the momentum squared,
we can separate the equation and
the same thing obtains for psi.
So similarly for phi.
Ditto.
Phi of b is equal to
the e to the i k sub b.
I'll call this k sub
a to distinguish them.
So the wave function's a
basis for the wave functions
for two particles, psi
of a b with energy e
is equal to e to
the i ka A plus kb
B, Where E is equal to h
bar squared on 2m K sub
a squared plus k sub b squared.
Yeah?
For a system of
two free particles,
is every wave function of the
form chi of a times phi of b?
If you have a system
that's separable,
is every wave function, is every
solution itself, separated?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Because we can have
arbitrary superpositions
of forms of this type.
So we get superpositions
of plane waves
as long as the energies of each
plane wave in the superposition
are equal to e-- the total
energy is equal to e-- I
can just superpose
them and I still
have an energy eigenfunction.
Everyone cool with that?
OK.
So nothing shocking here.
But I did this
example so that we'd
have the notation of chi
and phi for the two states.
OK.
So now let me come to
this question of what
about the proton?
Well suppose I have a system now
which is not a free particle.
It's two particles, a and b.
And e is equal to pa squared
over 2a plus pb squared
upon 2mb.
Plus a potential that
depends only on a minus b.
OK?
So this is, for example,
what happens in the Coulomb
potential when you include the
proton having a finite mass
instead of being infinitely
massive and stuck still.
So now we can do
exactly the same thing
we did in classical mechanics
when you have a potential that
only depends on the
distance between two things.
I can reorganize
degrees of freedom
into the center
of mass position.
R is equal to 1 over ma plus
mb of ma, a, plus mb, b.
So that's the center
of mass motion.
And the relative distance
is equal to 1 over-- whoops.
I don't need that.
A minus b.
And then if you do this and you
write out the energy operator,
e is equal to
minus h bar squared
upon 2 capital M, total mass.
Dr squared Plus 1 minus h bar
squared over 2 mu d little r
squared plus v or r.
OK?
So this is exactly what
happens in classical mechanics.
You work in terms of the
center of mass coordinate
and the relative coordinate.
The relative coordinate
becomes effectively
an independent degree of
freedom with a potential,
which is the central potential.
And the center of mass
coordinate is a free particle.
So if we have a proton
and our electron
and they're attracted
to each other by Coulomb
there's a center of mass motion.
And then they do
together whatever
they do together, a
la Coulomb potential.
Everyone cool with that?
The only difference is that the
mass in the Coulomb potential
is not the mass of
the bare electron.
But it's the
geometric mean mu is
equal to ma and b
over ma plus mb.
Now for a proton
and an electron,
if ma is the proton
and mb is the electron,
then this is proton electron
over proton plus electron.
But proton is about 2,000
times the mass of the electron.
So this is basically the mass of
the proton and they factor out.
So the effective reduced mass
is roughly equal to the electron
mass.
Corrections of a part in 1,000.
OK?
So to answer your
question, is the proton
also in some complicated
state described it?
Well in fact, neither the
electron nor the proton
are described by the
Coulomb potential.
But the relative position,
the relative radial distance
between them, is controlled
by the Coulomb potential
and the center of mass degree
of freedom is a free particle.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Good.
So, so much for that example.
The free particle and
the central potential.
Here's the much more
interesting that
happens when we have
multiple particles.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain what
you mean by the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, sorry.
This is the-- I generated the
gradient with respect to r.
So if r is a vector,
this is the gradient
with respect to r, norm squared.
And this is the
gradient with respect
to the relative coordinate.
So for example, this is--
if we're in one dimension,
so this is strictly
one dimensional.
Then this is just the derivative
with respect to r squared.
And this is derivative with
respect to little r squared.
Just the gradient squared.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What about in hydrogen?
PROFESSOR: Well then
it's gradient operator.
The thing that takes
the function gives you
a vector which is the
directional derivative
of that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
In the r direction.
AUDIENCE: Is that
subraction right there?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is that a
subtraction between--
PROFESSOR: A subtraction.
Where?
AUDIENCE: Between the first
and second [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Minus h bar
squared upon 2m, dr squared.
Minus h bar squared
over 2 mu, dr-- this?
AUDIENCE: OK, so that's--
those are separate terms,
not multiplied?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
They're not multiplied, right?
It's just the sum.
So the energy is kinetic
energy of the relative--
of the center of mass.
Kinetic energy of the
relative degree of freedom.
And then potential energy.
Which is exactly what happens
in classical mechanics.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's that
circle under the first term?
PROFESSOR: This one?
M?
It's the total mass.
Ma plus mb.
And this one is the reduced
mass ma mbu upon ma [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So here's a cool
thing that happens
with multiple particles that
didn't happen previously.
Suppose we have
identical particles.
So in particular, imagine
I have two billiard balls.
So I have two billiard balls
and I shoot-- I send one
in from one side.
And I send in the other
in from the other side.
And then they
collide and there's
some horrible
chaos that happens.
And one goes flying out
to this position, a.
And the other goes flying
out to this position, b.
OK?
Now here's my question.
Which ball went to a and
which ball went to b?
Well if we did this experiment,
that would be easy to answer.
Because we could paint a little
1 on this one and a little 2
on this one and
they'd go flying out.
And then at the end, when
you catch the ball at a
and you catch the ball at b, you
can grab them and look at them
and say aha, this one in my
left hand which I got from a
has 1 on it, and this one
has 2 on it, and I'm done.
The other way we could have
observed which ball went where
is we could've taken a
high speed film of this
and watched frame by frame
and said aha, particle 1,
particle 1, particle
1, particle 1.
Particle 2, 2, 2, 2.
Right?
We could have just
followed the paths.
And we haven't done
anything to the experiment.
We just took a film.
We haven't messed with it.
We don't change the
results of the experiment.
We just watch.
Right?
Perfectly doable classically.
Quantum mechanically,
is this doable?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Because first off, if you watch
carefully along and figure out
did it go through this slit,
did it go through that slit?
You know you change the results.
100% white versus 50-50.
If you go back to the boxes.
And meanwhile, if they're
truly identical particles
like electrons, there's
no way to paint anything
on the damn particle.
They're just electrons.
And they're completely,
as far as anyone's
ever been able to tell,
completely and utterly
identical.
They cannot be distinguished
in any way whatsoever.
So you can't do the thing
where you grab the one from a
and grab the one from b and say
aha, this one had the 1 on it.
They're indistinguishable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We're going to
come to the Pauli exclusion
principle.
Hold on to that.
Hold on to that question.
We're going to come--
we're going to get there.
OK.
So we can't-- if we have
truly identical particles,
what we mean by that is there's
no way to run this experiment
and determine which
particle ended up--
which of these two particles
went to a and which went to b.
Everyone cool with that?
They're identical.
And what I want to understand
is, what are the consequences?
So the first and basic
consequence of this
is that the probability that
the first particle ends up at a
and the second
particle ends up at b
must be equal to the probability
that the first particle ends up
at b and the second
particle ends up at a.
Because you can't
tell which is which.
If you can't tell, it must
be that those probabilities
are equal.
Because if they weren't
equal, you effectively
have skewed the results and
they're distinguishable.
These are totally
indistinguishable.
So the probability that
the first particle ends up
at a. second at b, must be equal
to the probability the first
particle ends up at b
and the second ends up
at a, because you cannot
tell the difference.
This is what it means
to be identical.
That equals sign is
what I mean by saying
I have identical particles.
Cool?
So let's find out what the
consequences of this are.
Define the following operator.
And Dave Larson,
if you're watching,
this is the [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] p.
So I'm going to call this
operator script-y p sub 1,2.
It's the operator-- so it's got
a little hat on it, one more
offense-- which takes
the first particle
and the second particle
and swaps them.
OK?
So-- and I guess I don't
even need the 1, 2.
This p operator swaps
particle 1 and particle 2.
So for example, it
takes probability
of a to b to
probability of b to a.
But more importantly,
this swapping operation
takes the wave function,
the amplitude, of a and b,
and it swaps a and b, psi of ba.
Now it's clear that
the probability--
that the swapping operation
does nothing to the probability,
because the fact that
they're identical particles
means that these are
equal to each other.
So it hasn't changed the answer.
But just because
the probabilities
are equal to each
other, does that
tell you that the
wave function is
invariant under
swapping the particles?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
It doesn't have to be invariant.
The important thing is that
the norm squared of psi.
So in principle, this could
be equal to some phase,
e to the i of phi sub ab.
Let me call it theta sub ab.
Psi of a,b.
And if this was the case,
that there was a phase that we
got here, when we
take the norm squared,
the probability
remains the same.
OK?
On the other hand, we
know something else.
We know that if we take
the wave function psi ab.
And we swap it and then we
swap it again, what do we get?
I have ab.
But that means this is equal
to e to the 2i theta ab.
So swapping twice
had better give me 1,
so this had better
be equal to 1.
Let me write this
slightly differently.
This is e to the i theta
squared is equal to 1.
So what must be true of e
to the i theta of our phase?
It's a number that squares to 1.
So it could be
one of two values.
It could be 1 or it
could be minus 1.
That's it.
So what that tells
us is-- psi ab.
So that tells us
that p-- whoops.
P on psi ab is equal
plus or minus psi ba.
Sorry, ab.
Another way to say this
is just that-- another way
to say this is that p
squared acting on psi
is just psi again.
So the eigenvalues of p
have to be plus or minus 1.
Here they are.
So in fact, this
is-- let me phrase
this in a little
more correct way.
This tells us that
the eigenvalues of p
are plus and minus 1.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to figure
out how it can be minus 1?
If p squared is psi
then it [INAUDIBLE]
has to be psi [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How could we
add that other [? p? ?]
PROFESSOR: Good.
OK.
So let's check this quickly.
So the question is
how can it be minus 1.
How can that-- that doesn't--
that would seem to violate
our calculations.
So what this is
saying is that, we
know if we take p on, let's
say, p along psi of ab.
Let's say-- let psi be
an eigenfunction of p.
OK?
So if psi if an eigenfunction
of p, with eigenvalue minus 1,
then this p on psi is
equal to minus psi.
Yeah?
Now the probability is
equal to psi squared.
And so p on psi--
sorry, p on psi squared
is equal to minus psi squared.
We take each side,
it goes to minus psi.
So this is just
equal to psi squared.
Yeah?
Who asked the question?
Sorry.
Right.
OK.
So it leaves the norm
squared invariant.
So it's OK to have a minus
1 eigenvalue under p,
because that doesn't change
the probability distribution.
The probability distribution
is left invariant.
However, if we take p
squared on psi, that's
equal to p on p on psi, is equal
to the p on minus psi, which
is equal to minus minus
psi, which is equal to psi.
OK?
So this is the statement
that the square
acts as the identity.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Along the [INAUDIBLE],
we need p squared on side B
to go back to side
B. It would preserve
the probability regardless if
we had had the two [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
Why did p squared have
to be the identity?
Because what is p doing?
p takes two particles
and it swaps them.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: And if it swaps
them again, what do you get?
The original configuration.
Right?
If by swapping,
if by p, you mean
the thing that swaps those
particles, then doing it twice
is like not doing
anything at all.
You can define a
different quantity
which isn't this swapping
operation which does this
twice and gives
you something else.
That's perfectly reasonable.
But I'm going to be interested
in the operator, which
is just swap.
And if you do it twice, you
get back to the identity.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Cool?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So regarding
the defaults,
is what the operation is doing
is changed particle number
1, particle number
2, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well--
AUDIENCE: What does it
do with [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So at any-- given any
configuration, at any moment
time, right, pick your wave
function, pick your state.
For example, two particles here.
What the script p operator
with swapping operator does,
it just swaps them.
So it swaps the position of one
and the position of the other.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
And that-- you do that,
at some moment in time.
You do that to a state.
So in that experiment,
what-- I mean,
there's no answer
the question, you
know, does p swap them before
or does it swap them after.
It's up to you.
You can apply the p
operator anytime you want.
Cool?
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when you
extracted the probabilities,
obviously if you have a case
where it's really far apart
and the two particles
end up [INAUDIBLE],
aren't they more likely
that they have not
moved the entire
distance in between?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
sounds reasonable.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is disconcerting.
AUDIENCE: --kind of like the
wave function. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
So that's an
excellent observation.
Let me rephrase that slightly.
So here's the observation
that she's making.
It's exactly correct
and it's where
we're going to get
in a few minutes.
So the observation is this.
Look, imagine I take two
electrons, which for the moment
we'll just call
identical particles,
so we take two
identical particles.
Put one in my right hand,
one in my left hand.
And I just hold them there
and I wait for a while.
A while later, is it the same
electron in my right hand?
AUDIENCE: Probably.
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
They're identical.
I can't tell.
They're completely identical.
And so if you think
about this like you
do some like weak scattering--
if you did some weak scattering
process between these where you
pick them very far apart, very
slowly moving
along-- but they're
very far away so the
electrostatic interaction is
very small and so they repel
each other just a little bit.
If this system is,
in fact, identical
and if the wave function is,
let's say for the moment--
and we'll talk about
whether this is correct
or not-- if the wave function
is invariant under swapping
the particles-- let's just
imagine that it's invariant
and they're swapping
the particles-- then
there are two things
that could have happened.
The particles could
have done this.
Or there's also a contribution
where they do this.
Which kind of hurts.
And in order for the
system to be symmetric,
you have to have
both contributions.
So let's come to that.
But indeed, it's as if there's
some additional interactions,
or some additional correlations.
And that's exactly
what we want to study.
So let's get to that.
Very good observation.
So what I'd like to do
is make that precise.
So there are two
kinds of particles--
or three kinds of particles,
I should say-- in the world
from this point of view.
The first kind of particle
are distinguishable particles.
Suppose I have two
particles, one with a mass m
and one with a mass 2000m.
Say just to pick
randomly a number.
Right?
Those are distinguishable
because you can weigh them.
So you can tell which one
is the heavy one, which
one is the light one.
And you can tell.
Cool?
So there are
distinguishable particles.
And if we have
distinguishable particles--
I'll call psi sub d
for distinguishable--
then it's OK to have
the following thing.
Psi distinguishable
first particle
is-- the amplitude for
the first particle would
be an a and the amplitude
for the second particle would
be a b, could be chi of a, some
function of a, and phi of b.
This is not invariant
under a goes to b.
Because under a goes
to b, it becomes
chi of b, some
function of b, phi
of a, some different
function of a.
That's distinct.
But it doesn't matter.
They're distinguishable.
So that's perfectly fine.
It's not true p of ab
is not equal to p of ba.
But that's OK, because
they're distinguishable.
Everyone cool with that?
AUDIENCE: So p of ba is i of p?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
So p of ab, this
is by definition
equal to norm squared of
psi d-- and I should say d.
D. Norm squared of psi
d of ab squared, which
is equal to norm squared of
chi of a, phi of b squared.
Whereas this guy would have
been chi of b, phi of a, norm
squared.
And since those are just
some stupid functions--
I haven't told
you what they are,
just some random
functions-- then
they're just different
probability distributions.
So on the other hand, if we
have indistinguishable wave
functions, then psi
indistinguishable,
we know that psi squared of a,b
squared is equal to psi of ba
norm squared.
And this is not of that form.
So we have two possibilities.
I'll write this
as psi plus minus.
If I know one of the particles
is in the state described
by chi, and the other particle
is in this state described
by phi, this would be
an example of a wave
function with that property.
However, it's not invariant
under swapping a and b.
So how could I make it invariant
under swapping a and b?
Well I could do the following.
1 over root 2, chi
of a, phi of b.
And if I want to
make it invariant,
I could add plus
chi of b, phi of a.
And now if I swap a and b, here
this becomes chi of b, phi a,
but that's exactly this term.
And this becomes
chi of a, phi b.
That's this term.
So just swap them.
Yeah?
But we don't need
the wave function
to be invariant under swapping.
We just need it to be
invariant under-- up to a sine.
So the other option is to
have a minus sign here.
And this gives us that
the swapping operation, p,
acting on psi plus minus of
a,b is equal to plus minus psi
of a,b.
And the plus is generally called
the symmetric, and the minus,
the anti-symmetric combination.
OK.
So distinguishable particles can
just be in some random state,
but there are
constraints on what
states, what combinations
of states are allowed,
for indistinguishable particles.
If you can't tell the difference
between two indistinguishable
particles and you know one is
in the state chi and the other
in the state phi, this
cannot be the wave function.
It must be either chi phi
plus chi phi in this fashion,
or minus.
Everyone cool with that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about what we mean by p of ab.
So normally, when we
talk about probabilities
we say that, yes, if you
measure a system what's
the probability that the
metric value will equal that?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But if we can't
even determine anything
from that type of system, what
do we have a probability of?
PROFESSOR: Good.
So what this
probability means is,
what's the probability that
if-- that upon observation
in the system, I find
the first particle
to be at a and the
second part to be at b.
Right?
And I can check that
by saying like, look,
I catch the first particle.
I catch the second particle.
Is this a?
No.
OK.
Then that gives zero to the
probability distribution.
I do that a billion times
and I build up statistics.
And if I'm a fourth--
one out of four times,
I'll find a particle, the
first particle-- or I'll
find a particle at a.
One out of four times,
I'll find a partial at b.
And the probability that I
find the first particle at a
and the second particle
at b is one tenth, say.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So we can never make
that if they're identical,
right?
PROFESSOR: What you can't
do if they're identical
is you can't say which
particle you caught at a.
This is saying a particle at
a or a particle at b, right?
But it's-- but whether this is
the same or not of probability
that I find a particle at
b-- the first particle a b
and the second particle at a.
If you can't tell
the difference then
they're just a particle
at a and a particle at b.
OK.
So what does this give us?
So this gives us a
couple of nice facts.
So imagine-- that's
an exciting sound.
So this gives us a
couple of nice facts
with which we can find
awesomeness in the world.
The first is the following.
If you have identical
particles, then the energy
can't depend on the order.
If you have identical particles
and they're truly identical,
you swap them, then the
energy will be the same.
If it wasn't the
same, then they're
distinguishable by figuring
out what the energy is.
So in order that
they're identical,
it must be true that if
you swap the particles,
and then compute
the energy, this
should be the same as
what you get if you first
compute the energy
and then swap them.
Which is to say that
the commutator of e
with the swapping
operator, p, is 0.
OK?
But what that tells you is
that the expectation value of p
doesn't change in time.
In particular, if it's
some initial state--
if you were initially p on psi
is equal to plus psi at time 0,
then psi-- then p
at psi, p psi, is
equal to plus psi
for all future times.
P psi of p is equal
to plus psi of t.
OK.
So if you have two
identical particles
and the wave function is
invariant under swapping them
at some moment in time,
then it will always
be invariant under
swapping them.
It's a persistent
property of particles
that the wave function is
invariant under swapping them.
Yeah?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What about things that
like, become indistinguishable.
For example, you have atomic
nuclei like, for uranium.
And one of them is in
like a heavier isotope.
And during the time
that you're like,
holding them in your
hands one of them
decays, now they're
the same isotope.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's-- OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This
tells you something.
This is a very good question.
So the question is,
suppose I have an excited
isotope of uranium
that' s distinguishable
from some other
isotope of uranium.
I wait for a while
and then this thing
decays down to the
state-- it won't
decay to the stabilized
isotope of uranium,
but whatever-- it decays
down to-- we could
imagine a universe
in which it did.
It decays down to
a stable state.
And-- I mean,
uranium's never stable.
But anyway, you get the idea.
At which point they're
indistinguishable.
This sounds better.
Because now the wave
function should be invariant.
But it started out
not being invariant.
What's the problem
in this argument?
The system has changed.
In particular, something
went flying out.
So this is actually
kind of a nice way
to argue that there must
have been something else.
The wave function
describes a full system.
But if something leaves,
then it's not the same system
anymore and the
wave functions isn't
describing the same
degrees of freedom.
Something left.
AUDIENCE: But suppose we
keep track of that one,
we still can't swap
the two uraniums.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Then-- well, then there's some
additional constraint, right?
It must be invariant
under swapping that.
But it must-- but the
wave function also
knows about that extra
bit that went flying off.
And so the whole
wave function has
to be invariant under
swapping the identical parts,
but not invariant under
swap-- the invariance is not
just those two things.
They're correlated with that
thing that went flying away.
So another way to
think about this
is imagine two different
hydrogen atoms.
Here I've got a hydrogen atom.
It's an electron and a proton.
Here's a deuterium atom.
It's an electron bound to a
proton and a neutron glued
together, deuteron.
So are the electrons identical?
Yeah, they're totally identical.
So is the wave
function invariant--
does the wave function-- or
the probability distribution
have to be invariant under
swapping the electrons?
Yes, they're identical.
So the probability
distribution must
be invariant under
swapping the electrons.
However, is an identical
under swapping the hydrogen
with the deuterium?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
So it's invariant under swapping
the identical parts and not
the non-identical parts.
Cool?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this tells us that there
are two kinds of particles.
There are persistent--
or sorry, there
are three kinds of particles.
And these properties
are persistent.
The first kind of particle--
sets of particles--
are distinguishable particles.
If you have two particles
which are distinguishable then
you're done.
They're distinguishable.
Nothing else to say.
Two, you can have identical
particles with the property
that if you take p on psi
a,b-- sorry, p on psi.
If you swap the particles,
this is equal to plus psi.
And then you have-- so
identical with plus.
And you have three
identical particles
where if you swap the particles,
you get a minus sign on psi.
These particles are
called-- we have
a name for particles
of this kind.
Bosons.
These are called fermions.
My TA did a bad thing to me when
I was taking quantum mechanics.
And said, just imagine
them as little tiny Fermis.
So just take a picture
of Fermi in your head
and imagine little
tiny-- and this is cruel,
because I can't help it.
Every time someone in a seminar
is like, blah, blah, blah,
Fermi.
And I'm like, damn it.
Little Fermi.
It's really quite annoying.
So now you have it too.
Great.
So what are the consequences
of the fact that there
are two kinds of
particles in the universe?
These fermions and bosons?
This has a really
lovely consequence.
The first is, suppose
we have two fermions.
OK?
Examples of fermions
are electrons.
Suppose we have a wave
function for two fermions.
The first might-- what's
that probability amplitude
that the first is at a
and the second is t b?
Well it's this psi of a,b.
And the statement
that it's a fermion
is the statement that this is
equal to minus psi of b, a.
If we swap the positions
of the two particles,
we must pick up a minus sign.
This tells us in particular
that the probability amplitude
for the first particle to be
at a and the second particle
to be at a is equal
to minus itself.
Because upon swapping
the particles,
we get minus psi of a,a.
So the probability amplitude
to find two fermions
at the same place is equal to 0.
Two fermions cannot
occupy the same state.
This was the Pauli
exclusion principle,
which we needed to get
the periodic table.
Pauli.
Two.
If we have-- so this is
fermions-- if we have bosons,
psi of a,b-- let
me write this out.
So psi fermion or
boson-- so fermion
is going to be with
a minus and boson
a plus-- is equal to,
suppose I have two
particles 1 over root 2.
And one particle
is in the state chi
and the other particle
is in the state phi.
But in order to be fermionic
or bosonic, in order for this
to be invariant under
swapping a and b,
we have to have a plus or
minus chi of b, phi of a.
And here we immediately see
this Pauli principle at work.
If I could take the fermionic
example with the minus
sign, then psi evaluated at a,
a must be chi at a, phi at b,
minus chi at b, phi at a.
But if a is b, this is chi
a, phi a, minus chi a, phi a.
That's zero.
But let's think about
the bosonic case.
If we have a bosonic field--
or, if we have-- sorry.
If we have bosonic
identical particles, then
psi b at a with a-- for
our fermion, it was zero.
But psi b of the amplitude to
be at two at the same place
is equal to-- well, if b
is a, then these two terms
are identical and
we have a plus.
This is root 2 chi
at a, phi at a.
Which is greater
than what you might
have naively
guessed, which would
have been just chi a, phi a.
For bosons, they really like
being next to each other.
They really like being
in the same place.
And this will eventually
lead to lasers.
So from this simple
statistical property
under swapping, picking
up a minus sign,
we get the Pauli
principle, which
gave us the periodic table.
And is going to give us
in the next lecture bands
and solids in conductivity.
From the same principle but
with a plus, and the persistence
of this sine, from the
persistence of the statistics,
from the fact that we
have two identical bosons,
we get that they like
to be in the same spot.
And we'll get lasers and
boson [INAUDIBLE] condensates.
And next time, we'll
pick up with fermions
in a periodic
potential and we'll
study solids and get to diamond.